this morning a towering new biography of
one of the most famous writers in
american history
philip roth's professional and personal
life are right for examination
and blake bailey has done it in riveting
fashion documenting a career that
spanned six decades
including a long list of novels that
described and defined our nation from
the years after world war ii
all the way up to the 21st century we
sat down with bailey after he turned in
one of the most anticipated
biographies in years
nobody really knows about phillips life
he kept a very low public profile philip
did not allow personal questions
during interviews and i come along
and he says to me ask me anything you
want
from a seemingly normal middle-class
jewish upbringing in newark new jersey
philip roth would go on to mine works of
fiction that became sensations
the breakthrough came in 1959 with
goodbye columbus
which won roth the national book award
when he was just 27.
in 1969 portnoy's complaint
about the sexual fantasies and
proclivities of a young bachelor
became a runaway bestseller and turned
roth into a global celebrity
he created an alter ego nathan zuckerman
his main character in four straight
novels
later another series american pastoral i
married a communist
and the human stain if you're looking
for sympathy
you come to the wrong place the human
scene was made into a movie with anthony
hopkins and nicole kidman
one of the many times ross fiction was
put to film
villa move you're in the way most
recently it was an hbo show based on his
2004 book
the plot against america it is not
between charles a lindbergh and franklin
delano roosevelt
it is between lindbergh and war
this will put it in a nutshell in 2006
the new york times canvassed 200
uh critics and scholars to name the best
american novel of the last 25 years
okay on the final list of 22 novels
six were by philip roth now
bear in mind that 25 year period from
1981 to 2006
was less than half of philip's overall
career
and there were plenty of books after
2006 too so it is an astonishing
career but as bayley writes about
extensively in his engrossing new book
philip roth the biography ross personal
life was
just as scandalous as his books he said
to you
you don't have to rehabilitate me just
make me interesting
don't rehabilitate me just make me
interesting and then
when someone who he thought might say
unsympathetic things about him talk to
me
i would immediately get a memo of course
telling me all the things that that
person is likely to get wrong
ross first wife maggie martinson almost
wasn't roth was in the process of
leaving martinson
who battled alcoholism and mental
illness when martinson
in one of the most scandalous episodes
in american literary history
she takes a jar goes to tompkins square
park
finds an obviously pregnant woman and
pays two or three dollars
for her urine in the jar and
persuades philip that she's pregnant and
he marries her
that incident i think may have defined
his life more than anything else
absolutely defined his life um he chekov
said i had to squeeze the surf out of me
drop by drop
and phillip said i had to squeeze the
nice jewish boy
out of me drop by drop so i would never
be victimized that way again roth was
both a victim
and a man who could victimize after
eventually divorcing martinson
who later died in a car crash he went on
to have a long relationship
with and married actress claire bloom
the affairs
roth carried on while he and bloom were
together were exposed in bloom's 1996
memoir
leaving a doll's house which badly
tarnished roth's reputation
philip's a flawed human being he kept up
a florida love life behind claire's back
for almost 20 years
but he was not this sinister
machiavellian
figure bent on persecuting her which is
the basic tenor of her memoir and indeed
claire often has said in public
interviews that her relationship with
philip roth was the most wonderful of
her life
was he a misogynist it's complicated
i know what philip would say because he
would say no he often said it to me he
would say it's ridiculous
you know he said i've had lifelong
friendships with in
intellectual women that said philip did
not have a monogamous bone in his body
following the bloom book roth continued
churning out fiction into his late
70s and only retired from writing in
2012.
he died in 2018 and spent a good part of
his final years trying to shape his
legacy
that included talking in uncomfortable
detail with bayley
and leaving his fortune to the newark
public library
a large collection of his books and
personal items will eventually be
displayed
in the new phillip roth room the library
should be able to operate for decades
in good health thanks to his gift not
far away near an intersection that now
bears his name
roth's childhood home it's interesting
to see i mean i didn't realize it was a
historic site
uh yes that went up uh in october of
2005 on philip roth day
in newark and it begins it says philip
roth one of the greatest writers of the
20th and 21st centuries
of course all that was written by philip
himself
of course it was of course it was but
the scope
and skill involved in bailey's biography
which took him almost
10 years to research and write is a
marvel to read
how do you think this book will change
the opinion of philip roth
i think philip himself would have liked
the book i think that that
parts of it obviously would have made
him extremely uncomfortable and
embarrassed
but for the most part i think a very
touching
human being emerges from that
i certainly felt very tenderly toward
phillip but it was impossible
not to feel tenderly toward philip if
you knew him well
if an eight to 900 page book can be
simulating
uh this one is at times it times it i
mean some of the personal details reads
like a high-end soap opera
almost but hats off to blake bailey who
as we said devoted
nearly a decade of his life to this and
you see it on these pages
i love that he donated the money to the
public library there
so important to keep that and that
legacy will be kept alive for
generations to come newark's on a
comeback that's right
right there